Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! Thank you everyone
that submitted questions on my game of thrones
video last night I think everyone feels like
episode 8 is the best episode this season
so far it was thought to more but it's going
to be really hard to top a white walker battle
most the questions that I saw people asking
were related to that but I did try to include
some aria in Cersei stuff to Ramsey is really
pest when you forget them too. Just give over
her spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet during questions schizo asks are there
different levels of Wights aside from the
top commanders and the ones that seem like
skeletons so you talking about like you know
the difference between White Walkers white
So you're talking about everyone that we saw basically. it's a lot simpler than you think so what you have
from the top down you have the Night's King
then you have White Walkers then you have
the Wights they also they're also able to
turn animals that's how they write the words
as they the undead horses so that means they
can turn other animals to seek and consider
those a different type of white they don't
really differentiate between humanoid Wights
there all the same most people feel like when
the winters going to be the book were George
RR Martin gets really the bottom White Walkers
and in their culture as for right now we don't
know a lot about what's going on inside the
minds of Wights it doesn't look like it's
a hive mind situation it looks like they have
some sort of basic mental functions like they
know what their target is probably defined
by the Night's King or the White Walkers that
are commanding them is is that the white walker
gives them their target and and then they
just go after it is as simple as that you
know until they fall thick whenever they poured
over the cliff they were temporarily immobilized
until they reanimated again she can slow them
down but she can't destroy them unless you
use one of their specific weaknesses next
question handsome Jack asks can valyrian still
actually kill the others words the sword Jon
used something special like light bringer.
Document the weapon of his or her high like
a flaming sword no valyrian steel is one of
their weaknesses White Walkers the Night's
King in the Wights have some known weaknesses
one being valyrian still as we saw you know
Jon so driving glass which we also know about
there also week against Dragon fire but I
but obviously there are no dragons in westeros
right now we also saw on the season four finale
that there week against the magic of the children
of the forest next question part two asks
what do you think Ramsey needs his 20 men
for what you basically just get a leader raiding
party again Stannis he feels like they're
stuck in the snow so there completely vulnerable
this can be one of those big changes from
the book so I'm really hoping to see Ramsey
get his ass handed to him I think it's a synopsis
for episode nine but it says your stances
gamble pays off it sounds like Stannis is
still going to be around through the season
finale and I don't know if Ramsey is going
to die but it would be awesome if Ramsey were
to get captured just like the show had like
a really special fate in mind for Joffrey
unit for some of the worst people on the show
I'm hoping you'd say something really special
for Ramsey that is a good question for you
guys if Ramsey is going to go somehow either
this season or next season how would you want
him to go if you like the way a character
needs to leave the show like the spectacle
with which they leave needs to be equal to
the craziness of their character so Ramsey
being the most awful person on the show right
now has to have the most spectacularly awful
ending next question crazy back asks do you
think that will take elements from the younger
of storyline when Dany eventually comes to
westeros so you're saying you know like things
that they cut off from the show will they
give those to Dany or her other characters
a lot of it will just be in the form of Easter
eggs like in this episode they mentioned at
least like for both things like Ramsey set
up fees for crows you know in a wall winking
at the camera almost to just continue to do
that more and more is the show plot diverges
from the book plot but I do think though continue
to reference the younger of storyline and
is always metaphors the you can drop you know
sometimes there there kind of far-reaching
like saying that Sir Jorah is Jon Connington
is a bit of a stretch they just have some
similarities right now without the writers
you know coming coming out and saying specifically
yeah we reference this one character this
one straight on the but it's really open to
interpretation just in the name of fun I'm
always willing to entertain ideas but you
just just remember that a lot of it is just
fan berries for now they just assume there
is no younger of character on the show and
that that storyline is to is completely gone
and that there storyline will just proceed
according to what Dan and Dave felt like George
R Martin was going to do with her next question
collected casks and everyone hates all a but
if you're just a kid and your family got slaughtered
and someone wanted to help the guys who did
it I be pretty salty to yet there's going
to be a whole lot of all the hate at the end
of this season there is even like a sub credit
right now I think called I hate all the so
just be be prepared for that everyone I think
all is going to wind up getting a lot of reverse
Joffrey hate like you hate Joffrey because
he is such a douche because it's so crazy
but people will hate all the for the same
reasons even though technically he is not
a character like Joffrey is not an evil character
is supposed to sympathize with them but you
made some things are just so ridiculous that
you can't forgive him next question Cassie
asks do the others practice blood magic and
if so maybe the Night's King captured bench
and start to use his blood somehow well you
know we don't there's a lot we don't know
about the White Walkers is far as we know
there magic is completely different from the
magic of the right God acolytes of both gods
you White Walkers as well as priests of the
right God can resurrect people so I mean there's
certain similarities and abilities but the
way they go about it feels like it's a little
bit different is one of those things that
George RR Martin just hasn't explained that
in the books that that's what were waiting
for whence a winter is like please explain
these things that are very complicated very
interesting there a lot of different gods
I game of thrones a lot of different religions
that I think are distinct you know it's not
like people just misinterpreting things it's
really just to God's rating the best way to
think about white walker magic is primarily
based on ice and necromancy thematically it
makes sense that they would just put it forward
is is like a winter relocating type of magic
but just keep making ice references your necromancy
just the tip of the iceberg is no really good
explanation so you I feel like characters
like Samwell organ explain things like this
in season six and season seven the characters
that read a lot of books that there are a
whole lot of people live there are masters
of those crafts and is not like the Night's
King going to do an evil guy monologue anytime
soon at explaining his grand plan and how
everything works that would be hilarious this
question to A source asks does winter follow
the Wights wherever they go visit him like
to they control winter weather or to the Wights
just move with winter storms are outdated
it's a combination of two you know the world
is like slowly getting closer but a lot of
it has to do with the magic of the great other
the Night's King seems like he's pretty powerful
so I would say you know he probably is a small
level of control over the weather but it's
not like he has like a winter infinity goblin
break and just snap his fingers and then turning
the world to complete winter overnight so
the winter storm that we saw in this episode
is probably something that the White Walkers
in the Night's King conjured up but during
the long night just imagine that winter storm
covering all of westeros next question space
Gypsy asks since we found out Balerion steel
is also capable of killing White Walkers and
it's in such short supply do you think that
Jon will melt down his blade into arrowheads
for the Wildlings to use know I added the
ability that they probably don't have anyone
that can reshape valyrian still there remember
Tywin had descendent for someone overseas
like that is such a rare trade they didn't
say specifically on the show but Samwell does
find like a cash of Dragonglass historically
in the early years after the wall was built
like right after the long night the children
of the forest would give Dragonglass shipments
to the nights watch to help them if for some
reason it showed just the size to forget that
plot point that they could always send someone
back to Dragonstone to get more number Dragonstone
is covered with driving glass so they're smart
enough to look for it. There is a lot more
Dragonglass that they can use at the nights
watch the question is is will Alliser thorn
in his ass holes listen to Samwell and Jon
like will they go for driving glass or safe
that's all bull crap right now about half
the nights watch only wants to kill the Wildlings
and the not thinking about anything else next
question Mary Jo Brian asks regarding Jorah
Tyrion should've advised her to send him on
a quest is that you know instead of just like
out right banishing him you I think he'll
definitely be back next season unless he dies
in the finale still worried like Jorah just
feels like a character this way too interesting
to throw them away he does have grayscale
but it's killing them slowly enough that he
could live through the entirety of season
six of the writers wanted to go that direction
I feel like Daenerys is going to the same
type of storyline it is Jon snow that does
a lot of like parallels between the two of
them Jon snow started by battling the Wildlings
then they realize that they have a common
enemy that's way worse so they did put their
differences aside and serve working together
I think Daenerys is just like a few steps
behind that she'll eventually realized that
she needs Jorah's help because of this bigger
enemy of the herpes of you really want to
compare like apples oranges between storylines
if you like the harpies are Daenerys's version
of the Wildlings she needs to turn all the
people of Meereen into her allies because
the real common thread is the White Walkers
even though she hasn't seen them yet so I
think of it almost Jorah smart for some spectacular
gladiator death in the arena he will be back
with Daenerys and Tyrion by season six thank
you so much everyone for so many questions
are always a ton of fun today I did see a
lot of people were asking about when you winter
officially begins technically the city and
all data notes on like the masers in the settled
to find when winter begins they can control
the calendar that way there are a couple different
concepts associated with that first there's
winter like you winter is is like basically
when it's snowing all the way down in Kings
Landing the long night as as Jon said would
be like a winter that covers the entire earth
when is like snowing in Marine a lot of people
are also asking about aria in the moneylender
so just explain that row quick the recent
Jaqen is sinking aria or your cattle the canals
everyone think about her on the moneylender
is because he isn't paying out what you would
call insurance money to the families of sea
captains who die at sea is a good do she insurance
agent who isn't paying out insurance and congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner and seeing
brave katniss, you win an HBO Now subscription just be
sure to DM me on the on the back of my channel
so I can get your contact info it's it's on the
About Page a lot of you also asked for like
some specific bonus videos on White Walkers
and stuff like that I might do some updates
but I have done a few older videos like I
did some video last year on that stuff so
check the description for extra links so just
in case you just haven't seen it you can click
here for my episode a video from last night
and can click here to learn all about Euron
Greyjoy. Thank You so much for watching, everybody
High Five and I'll see you guys Tonight!